all right welcome everybody I was not it
didn't seem like there was going to be a
press conference today and then one was
announced for Donald Trump actually
tweeted that it was going to be at 6:45
p.m. Eastern
then it I guess an official announcement
saying 7:00 p.m. Eastern which is 20
minutes from now which gives us a little
bit of time to talk about things so I am
here we will be playing bingo I will get
you the bingo boards momentarily we are
just going to give a little bit of time
for people to get connected and to join
the stream welcome on Twitter twitch
YouTube and Facebook of course I did not
stream yesterday took really pretty
close to a full 48 hours off of stuff
read very few headlines yesterday went
for a run
biking cooking you know these stuff that
people do um and in fact tonight I do
have a commitment at 8:30 p.m. Eastern
Time so that will be my that will be my
heart out today and hopefully if they
start on time and it's a relatively
short press conference as is expected
I'll be able to be here with you guys
for the duration so we will see remember
excuse me I have a sort of a tickle in
my throat that we will be putting super
chats that come in via YouTube up on the
screen in the bottom left where it is
currently an empty multi-tone grey box
and we will be putting you to twitch
subscription messages up in the vertical
blue box for example friends streams
just subscribed and said hey David loved
the show thank you so much for keeping
us informed your calm demeanor is
soothing thank you for being and then it
cuts off a great voice of calm and
reason we love you thank you very much I
appreciate that
so let's go through a few things while
people get connected just sort of like
the normal updates that we've been doing
official coronavirus case number one
point two six nine million as of right
now official death toll sixty-nine
thousand there is a new study which in a
part of Calif
I tested a whole bunch of people for
antibodies which means you've had the
disease and the Nate the numbers there
suggests that the infection rate could
be as much as 30 X the official case
rate now what's important to understand
is that's California California is not
testing that much California has done
2900 tests per million people compare
that for example to Louisiana which has
done 12,000 tests per million people so
in California the real infection rate
may be 30x the testing rate the the
infection rate because they aren't doing
that much testing in a state like
Louisiana or Massachusetts or New York
that's testing more the real infection
rate may not be that much higher not as
many times higher than the official case
rate but we don't know that is just one
part of California I'll have more
information about that on today on
tomorrow's program we're working on that
here in the United States the official
case number now is three hundred and
thirty-four thousand almost three
hundred and thirty five thousand again
the real number could be anywhere from
1.2 million to you know I don't know 9
million depending on what what you
believe and and you know we just don't
have enough information yet approaching
ten thousand deaths we have of course
still a hundred and fifty a hundred and
sixty thousand of the three hundred and
thirty-four thousand cases meaning
almost half are in New York and New
Jersey Connecticut also nearby but not a
huge number of cases as of right now we
do see Florida continuing to climb
increasingly rapidly increasingly
rapidly we expect that to very quickly
become a hot spot in terms of the peak
we clearly have not hit it yet more
cases every single day and as far as
deaths deaths go more deaths each day we
did have a little bit of a turnaround
here from April 1st to April 2nd but we
are hopeful hopeful that soon that is
going to turn around on that basis the
lit the ih Emmy model which I believe is
the best
right right now it's it's updated daily
that continues to predict that April 16
is going to be the peak death day the
peak is really going to be more of a
plateau and we are going to be above
2,000 deaths per day for roughly what is
that roughly about 19 days we are going
to be above 1500 deaths per day starting
any day now all the way up until early
May it's gonna be about a month we're
over 1500 people per day are going to
die
what is not sort of baked into this
model is the question mark around as the
temperature continues to go up in the
United States is that going to help
there is debate you know when you look
at the flu the flu has seasonality in
areas with seasons but there is still
flu in places that are warm year-round
so because this is a new virus it's a
novel coronavirus we just don't know the
level of seasonality that is to be
expected and you know we probably won't
know that realistically for for a couple
more weeks welcome if you're just
joining us we are standing by for the
top of the our press briefing from the
White House we're live on YouTube
Twitter twitch and of course on Facebook
let me do a few thank-yous I want to say
thanks to Tyler Klein who just grabbed a
membership at join pakman.com and his
new member number one tonight and also
Benson Flores Benson is new member
number two tonight at join pakman.com
you will all I am sure be thrilled to
know that the website has been
dramatically upgraded and has been
holding very very steady during recent
streams as people as people try to sign
up let me see if we have any does
anybody know if there's any stream right
now that is live in the room I always
prefer a live feed if we can get it I'm
not seeing one from the Washington Post
nor from from Time magazine but if there
is any stream that is live in the room
right now I would absolutely absolutely
cut to it but I'm searching around that
I'm just not finding one right now
PBS someone says is live let's see
Whitehouse PBS briefing let's see if we
can get that one streamed six days ago
let's see if I filter by live maybe I
can find it
yeah I'm not I'm not seeing that
Whitehouse PBS briefing I do not see
anything right now from PBS that is live
if time is live someone is saying okay
Whitehouse let's see time coronavirus
briefing ah I am not seeing that either
man that's weird
if oh here we go found it okay very very
good time is indeed live I appreciate
that
appreciate the assist from folks there
we go okay good always just prefer to be
live so that we uh we are aware of
what's happening in the room okay super
chats are coming in parity rensis did
your brain cells recover from earlier
Trump trauma they did and I have a bingo
board for you guys which I will pull up
momentarily kwb says I'm a fan of Joe
Rogan I disagree with him on Biden V
Trump but can understand his dismay with
Biden do you have any thoughts well I
may have thoughts which I will soon be
discussing with Joe I of it depends on
the virus but I will have thoughts Jason
Ealing says could you ever be friends
with a trump supporter it'd be real
tough real real tough Brooks Madden says
here's $5 thank you for listening to
Trump speak every day so we don't have
to well you sort of do have to because
you are here Thea's room Ramon Henrichs
says pronounced Oh pronounced riaj okay
riaj Ramon Hendricks was wondering if
you had a take on the exit polling
discrepancies in states like Texas and
Massachusetts I've not seen anything
that convinces me that there was foul
play and I addressed that last week in
more detail Tristan mcoppins says you
are very good looking sir oh thank you
Tristan I appreciate that fuzz the pie
guy says thanks David for your hard work
Julie Chao dari has grabbed a YouTube
membership and Claudio Bautista says
keep it up
mark Koontz says David thank you for all
you do
Anna Burgos says hey David what do you
think will be the future of New York
City do you think many people will leave
the congestion and spread in fears for
the second wave I actually address that
not long ago and I have a clip about
that which I encourage you to check out
okay bingo we are going to be playing
bingo today okay I am going to paste the
link for bingo right into the chat on
twitch as well as on You Tube
moderators please take notice so that
you can paste it when people ask you can
generate your own bingo board I did
modify some of the elements of the board
at people's suggestion we did this on
Friday and I made a few modifications so
let's go through what we've got today
the free square is tremendous we it
doesn't it's not really a free square
but from he's gonna say tremendous so
we're using that as the free square okay
Trump referring to something as perfect
or beautiful Trump saying we have the
most or the best tests Trump talking
about China Trump sweating visibly
here's an edition from last time
millions / billions industry pronounced
industry I've modified invisible
invisible scourge to also just be
invisible enemy because it seems we
didn't get scourge last time but we
might get enemy lot like you've never
seen before Trump referring to this is
we've never seen anything like this or
the economy will recover like you've
never seen before we added fake news
that seems to be happening more
frequently Trump swiveling at the waist
while someone talks that's when someone
else is speaking and Trump kind of
hinged let me see if I can do this
Trump kind of hinges forward and he will
swivel at the waist as he looks around
and it's physically physicists are
actively trying to figure out what
exactly is allowing that to happen for
us it's just a bingo element Trump
looking visibly bored and orange while
someone else is speaking we added from
the standpoint of this was heavily
requested a lot of people wrote to me
and said you really got to put from the
standpoint of
people are asking for the link I just
pasted it into the chat a bunch of times
and people moderators please keep
pasting it in first off we've added from
the standpoint of Trump mentioning
hydroxy or z-pak
the sir routine let me explain the sir
routine the sir routine is when Trump
tells a story of someone talking to him
and he'll say for example you know they
came to me and they said sir this is
gonna be the flu
that's the sir routine when Trump
recounts someone coming to him and
referring to him as Sir Trump calling a
question a nasty question a Trump using
war language about the virus a
subordinate thanking Trump for his
leadership that's a new element we have
we've added that Trump telling a
reporter they should be ashamed of
themselves Trump saying very strongly
blaming Obama which includes referring
to inheriting something from the
previous administration this is a new
one and multiple people asked for this
Trump taunting a reporter with are you
ready when Trump gets a question that we
would call journalism but he would call
nasty he will prepare for the answer by
saying are you ready are you ready and
then he gives the answer okay so that's
what we're referring to there many
people have said elements I'm keeping
because I know that Trump doesn't say
elements that often but when he says it
it's just it's just glorious so we've
got to keep elements on and then Trump
not taking or in some way deflecting
responsibility okay so these are the
elements of the board but you can
generate it'll randomize the position of
the of the different squares when you
you can generate
sorry about that that happens every once
in a while I put up the intro screen
we're gonna be playing that you can
generate your own board I you know it's
almost too easy to get bingo I always am
going for a full board that's my goal
I'm not you know bingo is like I don't
even call out bingo and I have it I'm
looking for a full board because that
that just seems to me like the most
likely it's the most fun thing for me
personally okay very very good so that's
that we are gonna be playing bingo
moderators will keep pasting the link as
needed if you are watching on Twitter or
Facebook you're gonna have to come to
twitch or YouTube we don't have an easy
way of pasting the bingo link into the
into any kind of chat or anything there
alright very good if you're just joining
us on YouTube do me the very small favor
of hitting the like and the subscribe
button both very important and they
really help us out let's take a look I
had a couple of clips here that I wanted
to play for you guys oh this is great
this is Brian Kilmeade trying to explain
medication to dr. Anthony Fauci check
out the looks on Anthony Fugees face as
Brian Kilmeade does this
75% of all everyone in Spain is taking
with success French and and Chinese take
it and the doctors are taking it there's
a lot of positive things and I would
look be very curious doctor to see if
anyone who's taking this for lupus or
arthritis has gotten cause of the corona
virus that would be one way to go the
other way to see about this study but
let's talk about some way to get get I
do you want to respond to that no I mean
obviously this is a good drug in many
respects for some of the diseases you
mentioned and the one thing we don't
want to happen is that individuals who
really need a drug with a proven
indication don't have it available but
just one guy can't escape getting back
to you said 75% of doctors think that it
was 75 you think it works you know
that's not the issue no no I should
clarify because I said Spain seventy-two
percent of the doctors in Spain are
prescribing it okay good okay well
that's fine okay yeah so very very
awkward and of course this is just
idiots see what what is being referred
to as this survey it's just a survey of
doctors okay
it's what have you seen or have you used
what have you seen used or what have you
used and then what do you think is most
effective and again this is just
opinions things that are used more
frequently even if they are not
disproportionately more effective might
feel more effective a lot of this stuff
isn't really expected to do anything
like expectorants like mucinex those
aren't even really treatments for
coronavirus so when you look at the
survey kill means referring to
hydroxychloroquine was was perceived to
be useful by 37 percent of doctors
nothing was preserved perceived to be
useful by 32 percent of doctors so you
these these are not randomized
controlled trials that's what anthony
Foudy seems desperate to start beating
people over the head with and you know
the desperation from fox news to just
pair it everything that donald trump
says is is really really wild let me
remind you i am inviting you to grab a
subscription at join pakman.com we lost
sadly
385 members in March weep that to quote
Trump nobody's ever seen anything like
that before
people are tightening belts because of
the virus so as I've been saying I don't
want your last two dollars but if you
are in a position to support the streams
and our channel in the work we do
grab a subscription at join pakman.com
it's 2 bucks a month if you use that
coupon code 20/20 now or even cheaper if
you pay for the year then it's only a
dollar eighty a month consider yourself
invited and join pakman.com is the
website I'll thank people who sign up
like for example James Barnhart his new
member number three today
Erica wasman is new member number four
today
Tyler Kline is new member number five so
these are all really great people people
who we love and I invite you to grab a
grab grab a subscription let me paste
the bingo link one more time I think
before I pasted the link to my board and
you want to generate your own board so
I'm gonna paste it again and moderators
please take notice this is the one we
want to we want to use which allows
people to generate their own bingo board
if you're just joining us we are playing
trump briefing bingo today and we are
expecting things to get started pretty
pretty soon we've made some
modifications since the last stream
there were elements of the board that
didn't work really well and there are
elements that worked really well so
we've kept those and tried to continue
improving upon other elements so let's
see here oh and we by the way we've
doubled the hosting power of our website
since last week we had a total meltdown
a total crash of the site and right now
we have a total of it looks like 25
people somewhere in the membership
sign-up process and the website is
holding beautifully beautifully
beautifully steady so I really
appreciate that okay other super chats
here let's see what we've got as we wait
for the start where did we go here
Christy can Christine Kinsella grab the
membership
unders Olson said I've heard test kits
from China have 40% accuracy and masks
are being recalled coming from China is
this true I've not been able to
definitively determine that but I'm
gonna have a report about that probably
Tuesday Justin Smith says trillium or
tree house you know I don't really like
either of those of those beers I'm more
of a I'm more of an allagash guy I must
say I'm into a lot of the different
elements of allagash James is now a SOI
boy congratulations James classy Andy
says our Prime Minister here in Ireland
who was a doctor is going to work a day
a week in the hospital during this
crisis that's incredible
crypto chrome has grabbed a soy boy
membership Wade Bowen ban says David how
do you think the Democratic race would
be looking if we were still in the first
or second debate rounds today I have to
think about that I'd have to think about
that I'm not I'm not totally sure it
very different I I would guess very
different would be my guess let me say a
few other thank-yous Matthew Thompson is
new member number six today at join
pakman.com Ellen Mathis is new member
number seven at join pakman.com Paul
Fisher is new member number eight Brice
lust Rocco is new member number nine
today at join pakman.com pattern Nilsson
is new member number ten maybe it's
Peter when I see two T's I I don't
assume that but I also want to say
thanks to hold on I want to say thanks
to Stephen gyum Bess key who is new
member number eleven today and I think
that catches me up no it doesn't chad
hamilton also is a new member at join
pakman.com i'll think everybody else
after let's listen everybody
I've been working very very hard today
I'll tell you for a long time they've
been working but before I begin I want
to express our nation's well wishes to
Prime Minister Boris Johnson as he wages
his own personal fight with the virus
all Americans are praying for him he's a
friend of mine is a great gentleman and
a great leader and he's as you know he
was brought to the hospital today but
I'm I'm hopeful and sure that he's going
to be fine he's strong man strong person
today every patriotic American heart
beats in solidarity with the incredible
people of New York and New Jersey
they've really become a very hot zone
but some very good things are happening
in New York the first time where the
deaths were less from the previous day
that's the first drop so far so maybe
that's a good sign could be and the
hospital levels are starting to perhaps
decrease it's been very short but
perhaps decreased so we wish Governor
Cuomo and all of the people in New York
great and New Jersey governor's doing a
great job he's doing a great job in New
Jersey they got hit very hard I just
want to say that the full power of the
American government and American
Enterprise is it really is this is an
all-out military operation that we've
waged there's the war land especially
over the last number of weeks 50 states
and territories have now been approved
for major disaster declarations which is
very unusual thanks to the Army Corps of
Engineers New York City's Javits Center
is now one of the largest hospitals in
the United States it's designated for
treatment of the virus patients and
staff by hundreds of federal medical
personnel deployed from to Army Hospital
units and they're doing a great job this
was something that we didn't expect to
do but they needed help in New York and
we sent federal troops not only troops
we also sent a lot of very talented
doctors nurses first responders people
are now running Javits
also as you know the USNS comfort which
is in New York there's been a lot of
publicity about that coming in and well
that was not supposed to be for the
virus at all under any circumstances but
it looks like more and more we're going
to be using it for that so we'll see
that was supposed to be for people
having other medical problems but it's
very interesting because they're
virtually no cars on the road no
motorcycles on the road no no anything
on the road things that would normally
be taken care of we don't see any more
so we haven't seen that in a long time
it's perhaps a positive but the ship is
ready and if it has to if we need it if
we need it for the virus we will be
using it for that for not for obvious
reasons but if for any reason they need
it it's ready willing and able we have
the best doctors the best military
leaders and the best logistics
professionals anywhere in the world and
we're orchestrating a massive federal
response unlike anything our country has
ever seen or done we've never done
things like this like you've never seen
us or our medical people because of the
fact that jurisdiction states in
particular New York New Jersey the
Connecticut area Long Island now has
become a hotspot part of New York
sending a lot of things a lot of
supplies and now we're sending personnel
where it's needed military personnel as
of Tuesday will will have deployed over
3,000 military and public health
professionals to New York New Jersey
Connecticut and other parts of our
country 3,000 and that numbers going up
and we hope we're seeing a leveling off
in the hottest spots of them all so
we'll see you'll be seeing that over the
next few days let's see what happens but
we're prepared in the last seven days
FEMA has airlifted critical supplies and
protective equipment from every corner
of earth they're coming from all over
the planet including from within the
United States where the equipment isn't
as necessary since last Sunday cargo
planes have delivered almost
listen to this 300 million gloves almost
8 million masks and 3 million gowns and
many more fully loaded cargo planes are
right now on the way three big ones
landed today and these supplies are
being distributed directly to the
hospitals and health care providers all
across the nation so that that massive
amount of material that we're getting in
is being delivered all over the country
tomorrow we'll deliver an additional
600,000 n95 masks to New York City to
take care of the needs of the public
hospital system it was a request of
Mayor DeBlasio we've been working great
with Mayor DeBlasio getting him a lot of
stuff he's working very hard I can tell
you that and we're working really very
hard with New York City and with New
York State and at the request of
congressman Lee Zeldin
out in Long Island bomb-thrower we will
also be delivering another 200,000 n95
masks to Suffolk County where they need
it very badly so I guess that counts as
million see right when he said
nationally this and that will also be
deploying millions of n95 masks to other
locations that Admiral pull of check
will detail shortly the Admiral will be
up in just a couple of minutes over the
last 24 hours FEMA has delivered an
additional five hundred ventilators to
New Jersey five hundred and again the
governor has been very thankful we're
working very hard with New Jersey
including building hospitals we've also
sent an additional 200 ventilators to
Louisiana definite hotspot 302 Michigan
working very well I think with the
governor amazingly 600 will be going or
have gone to Illinois and I mean there's
a governor I hear him complaining all
the time Pritzker I hear he's always
complaining and yet I just said give me
a list of a couple of the things we've
done in Illinois and we're building a
2,500 bed hospital in McCormick Place
that's the big convention center in
Chicago and we're helping to stand
and probably will end up staffing it
because he's not able to do what you're
supposed to be able to do as a governor
vow attack is not performed well attack
then we're also sending a hundred
ventilators to Massachusetts so we have
600 to Illinois we have a hundred to
Massachusetts we have 300 to Michigan we
have 200 to Louisiana we have 500
ventilators 500 going to New Jersey and
this is being done by FEMA being
delivered by FEMA and it's some job just
think of that when you think about 500
ventilators a ventilator is a big deal
we're also establishing a federal
medical station in the Washington DC
area to help Washington DC and working
very closely with the mayor and
everybody in Washington DC at the same
time governor Inslee we appreciate this
of Washington state has returned 400
ventilators which can now be deployed
elsewhere in our country so the state of
Washington has done very well they won't
be needing some of the ventilators that
have been sent about 400 that's a lot
and we appreciate that he's able to give
them back he feels confident that they
are in good shape for the coming weeks
until we can declare a final victory in
the days ahead America will endure the
peak of this terrible pandemic our
warriors in this life-and-death battle
are the incredible doctors and nurses
and health care workers on the front
line of the fight we pledged to them our
eternal gratitude and everlasting
support they make all of us very proud
our country is very proud
we have people they love our country the
world loves our country most of it
probably all of it they just don't say
it I can report today that the United
States has now tested and given results
gotten results of one point six seven
million people that's far more than any
other country has been able to do there
it is and you remember we inherited a
broken system and developed by Tuesday
1200 brand-new rapid
point-of-care testing kits has been
produced by abbott laboratories great
company and they'll be distributed to
all of our public health labs that's a
15 minute test even less as well as the
Indian Health Service the CDC and the
strategic national stockpile so we're
gonna have 1,200 and on a weekly basis
we're making a lot more they go very
fast a very accurate test and other
countries are wanting them so at the
right time we'll be able to do that but
right now we're getting them to all of
ours so we've done one meeting in six
hundred and seventy thousand tests think
of that 1 million six hundred and
seventy thousand tests and we have a
great system now we're working with the
states and almost all instances but we
have a great system and the other thing
that we've bought a tremendous amount of
there's tremendous hydroxy and hydraulic
wind blowing drusy chloroquine which i
think did you know it's a great malaria
drug it's worked unbelievably it's as
powerful drug on malaria and there are
signs that it works on this some very
strong signs very strong and in the
meantime it's been around a long time it
also works very powerfully on lupus
lupus so there are some very strong
powerful signs and we'll have to see
because again it's being tested now this
is a new thing that just happened to us
the invisible enemy we call it oh
there's that and if you can if you have
a no signs of heart problems the as
rhythm Ison as rhythm Ison which will
kill certain things that you don't want
living within your body it kills their
powerful drug if you don't have a
problem a heart problem we would say let
your doctor think about it but as a
combination I think they're going to be
I think there's two things that should
be looked at very strongly now we have
purchased and we have stockpiled 29
million pills of the hydroxy chloroquine
29 million a lot of drugstores have them
by prescription and also and they're not
expensive also we're sending them to
various labs our military we're sending
them to the hospitals we're sending them
all over I just think it's something you
know the expression I've used it for
certain reasons what do you have to lose
what do you have to lose a lot of people
are saying that when and and and are
taking it dear God if you're a doctor a
nurse a first responder a medical person
going into hospitals they say taking it
before the fact is good but what do you
have to lose they say take it I'm not
looking at it one way the other but we
want to get out of this if it does work
it would be a shame if we didn't do it
early but we have some very good sign so
that's hydroxy chloroquine and as rhythm
Ison as rhythm and again you have to go
through your medical people get the
approval but I said things that I sort
of like so what do I know I'm not a
doctor that's right that's the key
doctor but I have common sense
the FDA feels good about it they've as
you know they've approved it they gave
it a rapid approve only for emergency
use that's deceptive because it's been
out there for a long time and they know
the side effects and they also know the
potential so based on that we have sent
it throughout the country we have it
stockpiled about 29 million doses didn't
you say 19 million two minutes ago so we
have a lot of it is it 19 or 21 works
driven by the goal of the brightest
minds and size we have the brightest
minds in science but would we're driven
by the goal of getting rid of this
plague getting rid of this
Gorge getting rid of this virus these
brilliant minds are working on the most
effective antiviral therapies and
vaccines we are working very very hard I
have met many of the doctors that are
doing it these are doctors that are
working so hard on vanquishing the virus
vanquish this thing We strongly
recommend staying at home practicing
vigorous hygiene and maintaining social
distance so your your just not going to
catch it it's the most effective weapon
in this war and I will tell you the we
are committing to the to you we're
committing to the people of our country
like few administrations few people few
professionals have ever committed before
they are that might in shower I see them
I see them before my eyes exhausted
people that I'm dealing with everyone oh
we don't have those did they haven't
left their offices they haven't left
their hospitals we meet with them we see
them and tremendous strides have been
made I think the vaccines will have a
report on that but the vaccines working
together with other countries we're also
working with other countries many other
countries and we all want everyone else
to be first we're very happy but we are
very far down the line on vaccines we'll
see how that all works Johnson and
Johnson's doing a great job working very
hard a vaccine would be great therapy a
therapy and therapeutics would be great
we'll see what happens in the meantime
you may listen to what I said about the
two drugs mentioned my administration is
rapidly implementing the largest
emergency economic relief package in
American history you've seen what's been
happening very perfunctory legions of
dollars and small business loans have
already been processed through a
paycheck protection program so
we went out on Friday and literally it's
become so popular it's been worked with
the bank's they get it to the small
business it's not working all about
employment it's all about jobs sadly I
want you to keep your jobs give a small
business funding to keep the workers on
the payroll and we're sending direct
cash payments to millions of Americans
and rushing aid to the hardest hit
industries we're saving industries there
does will be you'll be seeing it and if
we do more we're gonna do more and we're
gonna try and get directly to people
that are hit so hard but we're gonna
take care of our workers we're gonna
take care of our citizens we're gonna
take care of our small businesses we're
gonna take care of our large businesses
the airplane industry the the airline
industry a lot of great industries that
we have that are in trouble because of
what took place over the last short
period of times these are industries
that we're doing better for the most
part doing better than ever the airlines
were doing great oil was doing great oil
and gas and and the energy industry was
doing phenomenally well and got hit like
nobody's ever been hit before just about
like no industries ever been hit before
there's never been anything like this
but we see light at the end of the
tunnel
things are happening things are
happening we're starting to see light at
the end of the tunnel and hopefully in
the not-too-distant future will be very
proud of the job we all did can never be
happy when so many people are dying but
we're gonna be very proud of the job we
did to keep the death down to an
absolute minimum the least it could have
happened with this terrible terrible
virus in closing I also want to note
today is Palm Sunday and the beginning
of Holy Week for Christians in America
and he really cares all around the world
well we may be apart from one another as
you can see from our great churches our
great pastors and ministers are
out there working very hard but we may
be a part we can use this time to turn
to reflection and prayer and our own
personal relationship with God I'm sure
he'll be doing that I would ask that all
Americans pray for the heroic doctors
and nurses for the truck drivers and
grocery store workers and for everyone
fighting this battle I had mentioned
yesterday where I see the nurses rushing
into hospitals and they're putting on
their outfits and they're pumping their
masks and goggles in some cases they're
rushing into war they're rushing into
war and I see people from apartment
houses screaming and shouting and and
singing their praises it's an incredible
thing this is these doctors and nurses
they're running into buildings and
they're literally putting it on as the
doors are opening they're putting all
this stuff and running inside and
they're running inside the tremendous
danger tremendous danger but most of all
I'd like to ask for your prayers for the
families who have lost loved ones ask
God to comfort them in their hour of
grief it's a great hour of grief for our
nation for the world this morning I was
talking 151 for four days I said 151 151
countries this morning it's 182
countries it jumped up a lot so as of
this morning
it's 182 countries are under attack from
this monster with the faith of our
families and the spirit of our people
and the grace of our God we will endure
we will overcome we will prevail we have
learned so much we will be stronger than
ever and I just want to thank everybody
I want to thank the incredible
professionals on the task force also we
had a big meeting
day we were calls all day long to so
many different people and I think our
package to get everyone working when
we're ready is really turning out to be
successful we may have to make it larger
because it could be it has to be a
bigger really successful but all of that
comes back to this country we want to
get them back we want to get our people
back to work everybody wants to be back
we want to open up our country as soon
as poss do I have that so with that I'm
gonna ask dr. Burks to say a few words
and she's got some charts to show you
and thank you very much thank you
watch for the swivel now very carefully
Thank You mr. president as you can see
from the hopeful signs in Italy and
Spain where we see finally new cases and
deaths declining it's giving us hope of
what our future could be
there's the soil to give you an update
on where all of the states were we're
looking at this as states normalized per
hundred thousand citizens it looks very
similar to last week we wanted to update
you we've been covering throughout the
week the states that were moving on this
map you can see very clearly where New
York is as a state although this is very
much still centered in the New York
metro area New Jersey is the orange line
the Green Line is Louisiana that's
followed by Massachusetts and then
Connecticut and Michigan are together in
those lines towards the bottom and then
of course Washington DC is now visible
on this map which was not visible before
and the yellow line towards the bottom
is Washington State next slide please
so this just summarize all of the states
we're tracking very closely at the
county level so we're trade we're
tracing and tracking not only the
epidemic at the state level but
understanding what's happening in county
by county with new cases and of course
also the deaths
we're also triangulating that with all
of the laboratory data and just to tell
you how we're kind of doing that he
looks bored and
yeah I'm making the call there serology
is now about 36 percent positive they
were in the 40s so day over day their
percent positive is finally starting to
decline New Jersey's is increasing
however they're now up to 42 percent of
the specimens that come to the
laboratory are positive Louisiana 25%
Massachusetts 20 percent Connecticut
Michigan 20 percent District of Columbia
15 percent Washington eight percent and
then Illinois Colorado are at about 16
percent Pennsylvania which is also new
to the graphic is it about 12% next
slide please
so we could go back one I'm sorry go
back one slide one more all of the
states here
those are 38 of the states 38 of our
states have less than 50 cases per
hundred thousand they are testing their
laboratory results are consistent with
that there's zero positivity rate for
their laboratories are less than five
percent so this is how we're tracking
and triangulating both case reporting
mortality or fatalities and also
triangulating that with the laboratory
the New York metro area New Jersey
Louisiana and a series and Washington
State have all tested at a rate greater
than Italy in Spain I know many of you
were tracking that remember many of us
we pushed out a lot of those assays at
the beginning over the last two to three
weeks and I want to just thank Admiral
girar and HHS he's been working very
closely to make sure that the states
that we're having an outbreak had access
to all of their assays next slide please
lost her scarf so just to give you an
idea of how we're looking at this we
look at cases every day I want to just
thank my data team they spend all
evening compiling data I get at about
two o'clock in the morning and it looks
at all of these metro areas by their
granular counties so we can see the
counties that have new cases that also
helps us identify the
hospitals and understand what hospitals
will need ventilators or PPE so this is
the Detroit area it's Oakland and
Detroit Wayne County next slide we also
then also track mortality it gives us
insight into how many clients are in the
ICU need care we want to make sure that
we're meeting the needs both on cases
and really appreciating the frontline
health care workers that are really
saving many people's lives next slide
this just gives you an idea from New
Orleans we are now also tracking st.
John the Baptist Parish also but this
was the Orlean New Orleans and Jefferson
County and really tracking those on a
case-by-case basis to look for changes
over time and next slide is their
mortality a lot of coronavirus custody
so this is how we've been tracking and
tracing the epidemic as it moves through
states and counties and communities but
as we started we just wanted to note
again we do see hopeful signs in Spain
and Italy they have completed nearly
four weeks of mitigation with people
really doing social distancing staying
at home ensuring they were washing their
hands if they have to go out to the
grocery store they're extraordinarily
careful they send one person from the
family and so we can really see that
beginning to work and we're very hopeful
that over the next week although we'll
see rising number of cases of people who
lose their lives to this illness we are
also hopeful to see a stabilization of
cases across these large metro areas
where the outbreak began several weeks
ago so thank you for your attention
Wow I thought I would do is update the
air bridge first and then air bridge
doctor bricks and Rick geographically
aligning the supply chain that's Burks
bro
so the everybody had three additional
flights come in today bringing a million
gowns 2.8 million n95 masks 2.8 million
surgical masks 11.8 million gloves 18.6
thousand gowns on on three flights and
that material will be pushed out across
the nation delivered to hospitals
nursing homes across the country doctor
bricks went through british geography
and someone tell them so over the last
few days I've been aligning the supply
chain to those areas and then reaching
that's because I've been working with
her for weeks now every day and
extracting data from those areas on PPE
burn rates so for example I spent the
weekend talking to the chief operating
officer of toy Hakeem Barry time for
example then talked to the leadership at
Detroit Medical Center Audrey Gregory
talked to the Health Officer and Oakland
County Michigan and then also with the
Chicago health officer dr. Allison are
we so reaching down to the to a level to
understand their needs
so we're geographically aligning the
supply chain right you can see doctor
bricks went through these counties and
we're getting down to the county level
and then aligning it by priorities of
point of care public or public hospitals
first VA hospital
private hospitals nursing homes first
responders acute care over the coming
days we will be making a push to the
geographic areas that dr. Brix mentioned
increasing the time through the supply
chain to those areas to give them weeks
not just days worth of supply primarily
using our industry partners that we are
directing Cardinal McKesson med lines
Owen minor Henry Schein concordance
healthcare directing them to put product
to the hospital door the nursing home
door the first responders directly
directly to them we're also in the be
working to push out millions of doses of
[Music]
hydrochloric Oh hydroxy chlorine hydroxy
quit work in the distribution there to
push the st. the swing animus to the
same impacted areas working it to get in
the hospitals they need to get that
anything at all the pools chlorinated
right away right now working the
arrangements to make make that to the
hospital front door and primarily to the
local pharmacies so doctor can write
those prescriptions and you can get it
prior to having to go to all right
doctor bricks everybody Thank You mr.
president mr. vice president my last
appearance here I mentioned that the
president had given the Department of
Veterans Affairs very specific
instructions to be as aggressive as
possible in response to the virus crisis
and not only to protect veterans but
also to help the American people as many
of you know we have three primary
missions at VA one is support veteran's
health the other is to provide veterans
with benefits I'm waiting for
specifically leadership services but we
have a a fourth mission and that is to
support the nation in time
of national emergency both in war in the
peace we provide a bridge from the
federal government to the states and
localities during these emergencies as a
result of that I have ordered our
veterans hospitals to begin preparing
more than 1500 beds to make them
available both at the ICU and the acute
care level to the states and localities
across the country as a result of that
we have opened up approximately 100 beds
in the metropolitan New York area in
Brooklyn Manhattan and East Orange New
Jersey we will be informing the governor
of Louisiana John bel Edwards tomorrow
that we will give him access to our VA
Medical Center in Shreveport Louisiana
to come to the aid of the people of the
Pelican state I've also given
instructions to initiate the fourth
mission in Michigan we will be providing
the people of Michigan access to
hospital beds in both Ann Arbor and in
Detroit we've also provided a
pharmaceutical trailer to be used by the
governor of Michigan at Cobo Hall to
support the citizens of Michigan who
will be coming into that facility for
medical care
we have also informed the state of
Commonwealth of Massachusetts that we
will be helping them in their efforts to
protect their most vulnerable citizens
and to of their nursing homes so in
accord with the president's instructions
the 400,000 men and women of the
Department of Veterans Affairs are in
this fight we are in the fight not only
for the nine and a half million veterans
who are part of our service but we were
in the fight for the people of the
United States
Thank You mr. president and you all have
just heard from several members of the
president's white house coronavirus task
force yeah we are truly blessed to have
the kind of leadership that we have and
whether it be Admiral of check who is
organizing the distribution of tens of
millions of supplies whether it be dr.
Burks and dr. pouchy or analyzing the
data literally hour by hour or whether
it be that whole-of-government approach
that you stood up mr. president calling
on every agency of government cluding
the VA HHS and every agency I hope the
American people know at this president's
direction we are we are sparing no
expense we are doing whatever it takes
we're marshalling the full resources of
that council to respond to the
challenges facing communities impacted
today by the coronavirus and making sure
every community in America has the
support we've also as the president said
so many times we forged a seamless
partnership with states around the
country as the president just reflected
by this Tuesday with another 840
military medical personnel arriving in
New York City there will be some 3,000
Department of Defense and HHS personnel
on the ground to supplement and to
provide relief to health care workers
really at the epicenter of the corona
virus in the New York City area and you
just heard the VA is opening up opening
up the bed space in New Jersey I spoke
at the president's urging today with
governor Murphy and 500 ventilators
announced today being built on the
supplies that we have already provided
we were able to coordinate with him to
extend all federal coordination on
testing in New Jersey through May the
30th if the need is there and also
opening up VA beds
I spoke with Governor John bel Edwards
in Louisiana and was encouraged to hear
from him that as you heard dr. Burke say
that
that new cases were down slightly in
fact we're seeing a trend of some
leveling among all the governor's I
spoke to today and I know the what oh
what the Secretary of the VA just
announced about opening up VA facilities
has been a priority for governor Edwards
but I assured him we're gonna continue
to send resources and supplies and
personnel to support their health care
in Michigan today I spoke to both
governor Gretchen Whitmer and Mayor Mike
Duggan of the city of Detroit Governor
Whitmer oh and I spoke about a new
program in Detroit that will make
hydrochloride ro chloroquine available
for 3,000 patients through the Henry
Ford Hospital they'll be tracking in a
in a formal study the results of that
but at the president's urging I assured
her that we're we're more than prepared
to make hydrochloric when broadly
available to pharmacies and doctors
offices across the Detroit area as they
deem appropriate
I also heard from Mayor Mike Duggan as I
told you mr. president and he was so
grateful to the FDA not only for
approving the Henry Ford Hospital tests
that will be exploring hydrochloric won
but also for the rapid approval of the
15-minute test in fact mayor Duggan told
me that he was able to use the 15-minute
test this weekend to testify past 150
first responders who had been sidelined
because they'd been exposed to the
coronavirus they all got the 15-minute
tests they're all back in the line of
duty and the mayor couldn't have been
more grateful in Illinois I spoke with
governor JB Pritzker as well as mayor
Lori Lightfoot of Chicago as you just
heard not only if we have we sent 600
ventilators to the state of Illinois but
I assured I assured the governor I
assured the mayor that while the
principal focus that we have in the next
several days
is on the rising cases in the Greater
New York City area in Louisiana that
Michigan and Illinois are in the
forefront of our thinking and at the
president's direction we're gonna make
sure the people of Illinois people of
Michigan have the resources equipment
and support that they need the governor
did express great appreciation for the
fact that our Army Corps of engineer had
constructed 500 beds at McCormick Place
and before the end of this week I would
construct another 2,500 beds for an
overflow healthcare facility in Chicago
in fact mr. president
mayor Lightfoot told me that the Army
Corps was just outstanding in the job
that they have been doing and
constructing that extra bed space as I
close let me just let me just express as
the president did our profound
appreciation for a governor Kate brown
and and governor jay Inslee the state of
Oregon and the state of Washington are
leading by example Oregon sent a hundred
and forty ventilators to New York City
and they looked at their circumstances
and concluded that they could spare
those at the point of the need and
because of the of the low and steady
numbers in Washington State and in
California a governor Inslee today
announced that they were sending 400
ventilators back to the strategic
national stockpile and those will be
deployed at the point of the need you
know not only are California and
Washington state low and steady but
frankly as I talked to governors and
mayor's today I want to say to the
American people that we we are beginning
to see the glimmers of progress the
experts will tell me not it's not to
jump to any conclusions and I'm not but
like your president I'm an optimistic
person and I'm hopeful I mean the truth
is we're starting to see cases and most
importantly losses and hospitalizations
begin to stabilize stabilize America I
think about it I want to say to the
American people
if that holds if that's happening it's
because of what all of you are doing
it's because the American people are
putting into practice the coronavirus
guidelines for America you're listening
to your state and local officials you're
practicing social distancing you're
using drive-throughs instead of going
into restaurants and so on behalf of
your president and all of us working
really at every level I just want to say
thank you America thank you for
responding thank you for putting other
people's lives and the forefront of your
thinking putting it again over and above
your own inconvenience and difficulty
because of your efforts there is as the
president just said light at the end of
the tunnel and I'm absolutely convinced
with the continued cooperation patience
persistence and prayers of the American
people we'll get through this and we'll
get through this a lot sooner than we
first thought it would take just gonna
refresh because the audio became weirdly
on signal sorry sir I what has to but
they played surfeit there were the two
flights that came through we're at the
three place where did they come from sir
they came from Asia and then you were
mentioning all these supplies to be
dropped off the mast the gowns the
hydrochloric win how are you guys making
sure that there's gonna run of these
products you know you drop them off at
hospital a-and that people still rush
and go grab every basket
and question for you sir after and so
it's going to the loading dock and
there's an invoice and so those people
that are responsible for that loading
dock and that invoice they're going to
make sure that there's not gonna be a
first did you have a chance you get
orders for a lot more than sometimes we
think an area needs here we go
generally speaking we like to either
negotiate that down or give it to them
as they want so we've had a lot of
orders that we think are high but we
generally like if we have it if we have
for instance with the medicines and with
other things we like to give it to him
every day we're building up and building
it up very rapidly and deploying it but
we do get orders from some of these
states where we don't think they needed
we try and get it for them what they
want anyway okay today I didn't speak to
him no I did get a call from the
ambassador and hey it's a big it's a big
move going to the hospital that's a big
thing he's a great gentleman so I you
know I just hope he's okay you mentioned
the nurses the doctors the villages to
celebrate I'm sorry people they're
gearing up and getting ready the people
that are flying and celebrate him has
there been any talk on any level
whatsoever of some sort of either
compensation front of protection for
nurses doctors because there's been a
lot of fear there's been some people
that said I can't risk my family's
livelihood I need to go back to the ER
as everybody's talking about it and
we're talking about doing something for
them but we're really to look at it at
the conclusion we want to just we don't
want to focus on that now they're
incredible this they're not saying we're
not doing it they go in with good
equipment with great equipment and with
stuff that's not so good and sometimes
they catch it wearing the best stuff you
can buy brand new the best stuff there's
a very tough enemy but these are amazing
people no we are talking about something
but we're really thinking about let's
get it finished first before we do that
place
the Surgeon General this morning was
talking about the coming week being
among the hardest and saddest weeks of
our lives I was talking about lesbian
art Pearl Harbor our 9/11 moment you all
are talking about glimmers of hope and
stabilization how are the American
people supposed to bridge those
different descriptions that they're
getting from this administer I don't
think they're so different I think we
all know that we have to reach a certain
point and that point is going to be a
horrific point in terms of death but
it's also point at which things are
going to start changing we're getting
very close to that level right now and
the next week and a half two weeks are
going to be I think they're gonna be
very difficult at the same time we
understand what they represent and what
that time represents and hopefully we
can get this over with because this is a
very horrible thing for the world look
we're one country out of a hundred and
eighty-two now that I have 182 countries
I have a friend of mine he didn't know
we had so many countries in the world
100 because friends don't are now
affected by this so we want to get it
over with okay
how does that change the projections
that you were making earlier this week
we hope we can say under those numbers
those are numbers of death and we hope
we can say under those numbers that
would be terrific and as far under those
numbers as possible now if we did
nothing you know that number too but the
American people really stepped up so did
the professionals they just really
stepped up so we're hoping to stay under
those numbers and that means the minimum
and the maximum but we're hoping to stay
under the minimum number you know what
that number was the numbers that you
were talking about today changed those
I would say the answer is yes but I
would also say that we're not going to
know really in terms of the final pence
gave them the knot on that when we get
out to the end and we're probably
possibly not so far away we're getting
closer
but it's our goal to stay as far under
that minimum number the minimum number
as possible okay
that's what we want to do you do promote
these medicines extensively here how do
you not go so far as to be giving
medical advice and you said yesterday
you might take some of these medicines
even though you don't have symptoms are
you still planning to do that and how do
you calibrate being enthusiastic yeah
Trump's gonna take for a condom because
I want people to live and I'm seeing
people dying and I've see people that
are going to die without it and you know
the expression when that's happening but
they should do it
what really do we have to lose we also
have this medicine has been tested for
many years for malaria and for lupus so
it's been out there so it's a very
strong powerful medicine but it doesn't
kill people we have some very good
results and some very good tests you've
seen the same test that I have in France
they had a very good test they're
continuing but we don't have time to go
and say gee let's take a couple of years
and test it out and let's go and test
with the test tubes and the laboratories
that's the time I'd love to operatories
but we have people dying today as we
speak there are people dying if it works
that'd be great if it doesn't work we
know for many years malaria it's
question was would Trump take it soon
it's incredible what it's done for lupus
but it doesn't kill people that's one of
the things with a vaccine when we have a
vaccine we have to do tests because when
you inject that vaccine when they take
whatever it is they have to take we have
to make sure it doesn't have a horrible
impact destroy somebody
good so we have to test it for a long
period of time this one not so much
because it's been out there now I'm not
acting as a doctor I'm saying do what
you want but there are some good signs
you've read the signs I've read the
signs with the other one there's some
very good signs also different going
together works very well but there may
be an indication that if you have a
problem with your heart you shouldn't
take yes the call the Seebeck you
shouldn't take it and that's okay but I
would love to go to a laboratory and
spend a couple of years testing
something we don't have time we don't
have two hours because there are people
dying right now if it does help great if
it doesn't help we gave it a shot we
gave it a shot that's the way I feel you
know we passed something yeah I would I
would be super serious about taking it
that means now that's something I'm very
proud of it's go right to try for 45 50
years they've been trying it makes so
much sense we have the greatest doctors
and forget about you just bowing is that
a technician idea see of this greatest
medicines the greatest minds in the
world everybody admits it and when we're
close to having something or when we
have something that tests incredibly
well you couldn't use it for years
because they would take years and years
to test so with the help of also
Democrats I got it bipartisan but
they've been trying to get this passed
for four decades you know that it's
going right to try so a person would be
diagnosed terminally ill from something
and in the old days meaning before a
year ago they would say do you think I
could try this this pill this whatever
this medicine that's testing so well no
you can't do that you can't do that
under no circumstances they'd leave for
Asia they'd leave for Europe
they'd leave her if they had money if
they had no money they'd go home and die
with no hope we got a thing called right
to try if somebody's very ill terminally
ill they're going to die
they and it was very complex wasn't as
easy as it sounds because there were
huge liability problems
the drug companies didn't want to do it
because they didn't want it on test
results because these are very sick
people so they didn't want to bring down
their test results the insurance
companies had tremendous problems they
got everybody in the room and said look
question was will he be trying
chloroquine will say we're not gonna sue
the family is not going to sue the drug
company not gonna sue the insurance
company not gonna sue the state the city
or the federal government okay it's
called exculpation we got it done it's a
very simple agreement I'll write it down
you ever thought of it but they never
thought of it I did and we got it done
now we have right to try which is
actually in my opinion much more
difficult than what we're talking about
here but if there's a medicine or
something a possible cure or something
that's looking good and somebody has
something that's gone they're going to
die or they're very sick they take it
and you know we've had some unbelievable
results unbelievable results and it also
gives the people hope yes please the
doctors who are treating coronavirus
patients they have the medical expertise
to determine whether or not they should
person prescribe I see and many of them
and there are already clinical trials in
place looking at hydroxychloroquine
so if you won't finish in about a year
why not just let the science speak for
itself why are you promoting this drum
not every day right start talking about
the been eyes I want them to try it and
it may work and it may not work but if
it doesn't work it's nothing lost by
doing it now we may get some because we
know the long term what I want I want to
save lives and I don't want it to be in
a lab for the next year and a half as
people are dying all over the place
their doctors already able to prescribe
it all right well I'm doing what you
accomplished
I'll tell you what I accomplished we
bought massive amounts of it twenty-nine
million doses of it we have it coming
from all of the labs we're actually now
doing it here because in case it does
work we want to have it and we've given
it to drug stores with we're sending it
all over FEMA is doing it FEMA is doing
it we're doing it through different
channels so many different channels
including the companies that make it
it's a very special thing now it may not
work in which case hey it didn't work
and it may work in which case it's going
to save a lot of lives now a lot of
people say if the people walking in
prior to getting it if they take it it
has a profound effect well maybe it
doesn't maybe it doesn't I don't want to
wait a year to have to find out and only
CNN would ask that question fake news
there it is fake news bingo you've seen
some change in the projection I'm
wondering if you could you you obviously
have a week's more worth of data since
and you're a doctor in Toronto's room
100,000 at 240,000 potential death
figures that you gave us last week so
I'm wondering with all the caveats that
this is sort of based on continuing
social distancing that we might see you
know if one city pops things could
change dramatically what what are the
the sort of range that you're now
looking at in terms of total death
impact well we're not officially
updating that's important thing right
now is when we were talking about why we
are hopeful well hopeful because last
time I was here I wasn't able to really
tell you that Italy and Spain were
coming across their apex and coming down
the other side and I think to me that's
extraordinarily hopeful they just
completed completed four weeks of really
strong mitigation and I think that's our
word to the American people is we can
look like that to other countries look
like that now to other countries with a
very similar experience to our
experience with high higher case numbers
and higher mortality so that's what the
promise is the promise is if we do this
we could potentially be better now
doctor Falchi and I today got another
update from another independent modeler
and the numbers came in close to that
hundred thousand number again but we
believe doctor Falchi and I that if
every American follows the guidelines
six-feet washing hands not social
gathering that will have an even greater
impact and the other side of the
equation certainly is our remarkable
health care providers our respiratory
therapists our laboratory technicians
our nurses and doctors they're saving
lives every day and so that changes the
number too I also think that dr. Fauci
and dr. Brooks are very impressed with
the American people right and I'm not
gonna put words in anybody's mouth I
would never do that but I am and I will
say that they are doing maybe a better
job than we all thought even possible
when you look at streets in New York
with this nobody is look at some other
states though no cars no nothing I see
it you know I've seen those streets for
a long time and they're packed all the
time and now you see that no
you look at other places you look at
what's going on in California where
they're doing a fantastic job they
really are the governor's doing great
proud of them proud of a lot of people
proud of a lot of people on the other
side you know a lot of people really
really delighted to work with people
that frankly on other issues I didn't
get along so well with we disagree on
this or that we'd have to go into that
now but we're getting along with a lot
of people and they're happy with us
we're happy with them but I really
believe that the American people are
doing a better job than anybody would
have thought even possible and that's
one of the reasons we can even be
talking about the kind of number that we
hopefully will be talking about which is
at the minimum level instead of the
maximum or beyond it's not even the
maximum it's much beyond a maximal level
which would be means lower not beyond
secretary mentioned the Department of
Defense might be moving in the direction
of using face coverings by former Vice
President Biden I mentioned that he was
going to be using a mask whenever he
goes out now are we getting to a point
where we might see members of the krona
virus Task Force also wear face
coverings well it was voluntary as I saw
it yesterday and certainly if they'd
went to I would I would encourage it I
would have absolutely no problem with
that if they wanted we had a long
meeting today there's good separation
but the task force meets and I would
certainly have absolutely no problem if
they wanted to I think frankly it's
something at least for a period of time
where it might be advisable and you know
it's advisory and we'll see what happens
yes president
we've seen reports that Chinese
shipments testing kits and PPE have
turned out to be faulty to some capacity
we obviously don't have over we've seen
in Spain and you see the different
they're not sending faulty things to us
don't check it out please one of the
things we're doing to prevent that is
using those six companies that are the
ones in the major supply chain we are
actually going to facilities looking at
product inspecting it and clearing it
before it comes here so so you we've
we've heard those things that's why
we're that's why we're doing that okay
thank you and we're also sending you to
other from other location right and when
it comes to the ventilators which are
very complex we are now building we have
now under construction literally
thousands of ventilators so but so far I
think our projections on ventilators
have been right they've been correct did
you have something for who for dr.
Burgess and dr. faff see if they want to
take a crack at it some of the models
that you guys were using the IHM ii
model in particular has been very
accurate when it comes to projecting
deaths over the last couple of days but
there's a couple of other metrics that
they seem to be pretty far off on
specifically hospital beds are you guys
can you know happy with the models
you're currently using is there any need
to adjust those well it's turning out
that we need less hospital beds fewer
that's what you're talking about and
that's what we well we may have models
but we've been sort of saying that in
New York we were saying we think you're
gonna need less now let's hope that
continues but right down I heard
Governor Cuomo this morning and he was
saying less hospital beds also less
death that was a very big thing first
time less death today than yesterday
right that's a big thing but also less
hospital beds that means less patients
because basically it's less patients and
we were saying that and it also means
less ventilators so there's a lot of not
a very positive things happening okay
please
with with Prime Minister Johnson
hospitalized yes I noticed a few minutes
ago you were standing right next to vice
president pence or are you considering
staying away from each other just to
make sure that we have continuity of
government the executive branch we we
have this tiny platform and I'd love it
to be wider well they just shouldn't be
there from each other
Mike you were tested yes okay like
recently so was I a couple of days ago
he doesn't even get it and but I get
next to mine Oh breathe and I'm only
kidding we are we are sometimes forced
into positions that I'd rather I'd
rather be away but it's it's you know
you're all looking for questions Mike's
a very big part of this I am I would
love one or both of them not to show up
and just have it be doctors in this
distance on this little area
would consider leveling import tariffs
on imports of oils in the United States
well if the oil price stays the way it
is because of people that really want to
see it go up when I say give we want to
save a great industry that we built the
great industry in this country if they
don't get along I would do that yeah I
would do tariffs very substantial
tariffs because we're independent now we
have our own oil and if I did the
tariffs we essentially would be saying
we don't want foreign oil we don't want
any foreign oil we're just gonna use our
oil right and that would help to save an
industry and you know it's become a
tremendous job producer and it's great
to be independent we're independent our
energy is now independent we produce
more oil than oil I guess than anybody
else than any other country and that all
took place over the very recent time now
in the meantime I'm seeing $91 $91 on
the road okay a lot of people are happy
I see very inexpensive jet fuel we're
trying to save the airline industry but
I want to save cheap gas can't drive
anywhere cheap jet fuel can't fly
anywhere so I would I would absolutely
do that and what we'll do price will
still be very low but what we'll do is
we'll save and very importantly we'll
save tens of thousands of jobs one of
the other things we're doing is having
oil shipped to our strategic oil
reserves okay and you know we're buying
it for the right price and we're
shipping it in some cases we're storing
it for nothing
they're there we're filling up our
reserves with this very inexpensive oil
nobody thought they'd ever see a price
it's like from the 1950s where they had
big dollars okay so no I would use
tariffs if I had to I don't think I'm
gonna have to because Russia doesn't
benefit by having this and Saudi Arabia
doesn't benefit by having they you know
oil and gas of their major sources of
income so it's obviously very bad for
them but we have to we have an industry
that's a very important interest
and it's really formed beautifully it
was the virus that killed it because
what happened is it's down 40 percent
from the day this happened I think that
might be beautiful that would be doing
on it phenomenally well so that's it
yeah and then speaker Pelosi today I
think last night set in the next bill
that they would like to see additional
stimulus checks made have you guys
thrown around an amount of how much no
but I like the concept of it I think
it's good we're talking about a
different way of doing it but I like the
concept I'd like the concept of
infrastructure our country has to be
rebuilt
they spend all this money in the Middle
East eight trillion dollars for up to
now eight trillion dollars in the Middle
East we got to rebuild our country okay
we have to rebuild our roads and our
schools our bridges we have to rebuild
our country so I like an infrastructure
built I also like money going directly
to people it's not their fault that this
happened and I do think this especially
the faster we could get it open our
country can you believe we're talking
about our country getting our country
open the faster we get it open the
bigger the boom the bigger the rocket
ship going up I think it is a chance to
go really quickly relatively quickly I'd
like to see very quickly but we'll see
but part of the stimulus and part of
what we're doing that will help it and
the nice part is we're paying
practically zero interest rates you know
we're paying very little so one of the
reasons I like the infrastructure bill
because we're borrowing we have a strong
dollar and the advantage to a strong
dollars everybody wants to invest in
this country they will want to buy our
dollar at Trump now is about currencies
in terms of timeline still two weeks we
took in please
you're reasonably discussed it with the
staff we discussed it with FDA well left
FDA approved it so you know which is
another point I mean it's been approved
by FDA for emergencies very important if
it wasn't a pro grafter yeah then I
couldn't do this but FDA's approved it
the hydroxy will see if it works
no it's not gonna it's not gonna hurt
people it can help them but it's not
gonna hurt a couple people already
actually had a beauty of it you see it
can help them but it's not gonna hurt
them that's not necessarily true what do
you have to lose okay
questioning on the back please yeah
obviously we know anyone can spread the
disease right so why even not have a few
businesses open why not just shut
everything down there a grocery store
that are open fast-food places why even
take a little chance to stir no more
than a ham it will answer that question
later all I can say wait up right now
things are looking really good and
opening up with a bang will be a great
thing and there's nobody gonna be
happier than me please well answer that
later
the I HIV model suggests that 32,000
ventilators will be required by the role
GM is not expected to have ventilators
32,000 will be required across the
country in addition to the ones that
we've already said just don't forget we
have almost 10,000 a little more than
9,000 not asking the question super well
those are ready to rock [ __ ] I believe
them and we had to keep it you
understand that flexibility so that if
we need them in New York which we might
not if we need them but they're ready to
move we have we're already militants and
military operation yeah we are ready to
be moved immediately into whatever
section of the country we need would you
like to answer that correctly they're
worth FEMA is working on a plan to be
able to move ventilators so for example
the DoD gave another 500 ventilators
they're on the move being staged at Fort
Dix to be able to rapidly deploy them to
locations into to include you know you
heard the president mention States
giving to States things like that so
there's there's the ventilators that
aren't in use that they conceivably we
could rapidly move as well but you
mentioned that there were thousands that
are
being made any update with GM and Ford
it's gonna be month Ford we have many we
have 11 companies approximately 11
companies building them and we're gonna
have a stockpile for future hopefully we
never have to use them they should have
the hospitals the states should have
bought a stockpile they didn't do that
here we go that made up for it but if we
have extras other countries need them I
mean you see UK needs them badly France
needs them badly Italy needs them badly
they need them so it's complicated it's
a big piece of equipment it's expensive
and we'll be able to help other
countries after we take care of our
needs yes please go ahead as you
actually chose you but that's okay let
them go that's very good about how empty
the roads are these there any thought is
there any way to speed up in front of
the Beltway in Washington it takes
forever to do any road repairs because
of all right now because they don't do
construction techniques that work and
that are better I mean I see a highway
and that's which is what I do I do
construction what I did I see a highway
that's good but it's got a bad top and
it's got a big base concrete base
underneath and I'll see them come in I
don't want to say where but I could tell
you I could give you a plenty of
examples and they rip the hell out of it
they take out the base they take out
everything now they pour a new base that
isn't as good isn't as deep isn't as
thick the concrete base was fantastic
the footing it takes forever whether it
takes forever and instead of scraping
out the asphalt or whatever may be the
top scraping it off and putting the new
asphalt down putting the new median in
they can you imagine and then the then
they open the highway and it starts to
crack the reason is because it hasn't
been said truck doesn't like how the
medians are being done in our highways
more money than they have to I never
believed when I watch these people doing
highways and doing roadways and doing
work how they take the most expense
solution and the bottom line the job
itself is far worse getting at is taking
advantage of the fact that so many
people are staying at home not on the
roads is there a way to hopefully
they're not gonna be staying at home for
long hopefully this will be out and
we're not gonna have that kind of time
if we have that kind of time we made a
big mistake please go ahead the 15
minutes think we have a square for that
reflected on of the progress that
they've made in Detroit nobody else
responders back on duty with the Abbott
Laboratories tests Abbott Laboratories
started last Tuesday producing about
50,000 tests a day and there's I'm
informed that there are about 18,000 of
these machines already all across the
country I mean they are they're actually
the same machines that you use to get a
strep test quickly when you go to the
doctor but now Abbott is surging these
new 15-minute coronavirus tests out to
healthcare professionals and healthcare
facilities around the country in
addition as the president said FEMA has
purchased 1200 of these devices were
destroyed distributing them to all 50
states and the Indian Health Care System
and and then will DB distributing the
tests dr. Brooks is there anything to
add further
let me ask I believe there on the shelf
an abbot a good majority of them I don't
have the exact numbers I think there is
some manufacturing in there but large
balance of them are on the shelf some
have gone out by the way but sure the
big bulk of go out on Tuesday kind of an
aimless press conference today today
there's definitely a different approach
here I think with the the distribution
you know the sense of it in listening to
your presentation today is that you are
embracing taking a leader role for
distribution is there a change no
there's not a change but we're supposed
to be the backup but like in Illinois
the governor couldn't do his job
so we had a help we said that's
definitely laters a sort of deflecting
responsibility or make place we're doing
so we have some people that were not
able to do we have other people that
needed a little help we had in New York
we had to give a lot of help but we've
worked very well with Governor Cuomo and
with mayor de Blasio but no we are meant
to be the backup but we've taken on a
much bigger role than that and that's
okay I have no objection to it now in
some cases just work so well where
they're actually now seeing they think
they're over over the big problem and
they're actually calling us and they're
saying you can take your equipment back
now but we're really deployed as a
backup but I feel with much more than
that they've done a much better job I
will say this I don't think that the
people that have represented this
country the federal government whether
it's the Admiral and the generals that
all of the people that we call - before
I just they're heroes for what they've
done what they've been able to do in a
short period of time they took a system
that was broken just like we did the
military our military was broken our
military was depleted and it was
broken that's a lie we built our
military total I've rebuilt this whole
system too and I in a way Kelly I
appreciate your question because you
know you're hearing all of the things
that we're that the millions of masks
the hundreds of thousands of gowns and
their surgical you know their their
protective gear these aren't ball gown
that's the highest level we're getting
it to the various states and most of the
governors are very happy now a lot of
times you know it's politics maybe I do
the same thing I don't know but they'll
try and act not so happy I will tell you
when I speak to them or when vice
president speaks to them they're singing
the praises of all of these people so I
always take umbrage when when somebody
says something about we're done now to
do this to do this should have taken to
do what we've been able to do and to
build it to a level should have taken a
year who should have taken two years
they did it in a matter of weeks and
we're helping States know it's them as
an example New York had the right to buy
16,000 ventilators they could have
bought him they didn't I understand why
they did it was a very expensive
purchase you know very expensive and
that's a lot 16,000 and they chose to do
something else with their money I
understand that the problem is when
something like this comes along which
you don't expect look 1917 that's a long
time why doesn't he say nineteen eight
perhaps a hundred million people died
that's a long time ago so people don't
think it's gonna happen I would have
frankly I mean did anybody in this room
think a thing like this could happened
but it happened and we built up a force
this is a military operation as it
turned out it really is with with FEMA
with the Army Corps of Engineers I mean
Army Kervin and you were very gracious
on that point the Army Corps of
Engineers building
2,500 units of beds and everything else
now and then Governor Cuomo called and
he wanted it to go covert meaning for
the problem
and we said well it wasn't supposed to
be that way but we want to get it done
and we move military personnel so now
military personnel are operating it and
I'll tell you what's what's good it
hasn't been very full that's a good
thing not a bad thing it hasn't been now
maybe over the next week something will
happen but it hasn't been but we have
because it's better than the other
alternative where we run out but what is
in talking about actually 2,900 beds and
we have also we built for medical
centers in New York we've built for
hospitals for medical centers and a lot
more than that it's such an honor to
have done it but the people that did it
are amazing and they have to be
appreciated by the states not me they
don't have to appreciate me at all
I don't care about me good they have to
appreciate the generals the Admirals the
doctors the nurses I mean we're bringing
now 3,000 people in there are medical
professionals that are coming from all
over the country to help New York City
help New York State and help many other
places I just think it's incredible what
they've done and I don't think that
they've been appreciated me you can
forget about me you can see yeah I wrote
I actually mean it they have to be
appreciated go in the back please I
didn't I would not be I would not be
very thrilled with what we've done
no I see light at the end of the tunnel
I think indications are some of the
numbers coming out today I think you
know we had a very good meeting today
we're seeing things that we don't even
report because we think it's too early
to report no I think you know we're
seeing things happen that are very good
and we also know all of us including the
medical profession he didn't even let
her ask the question yet we have to open
a country up we have to get go we have
to open our country no country was
designed for this will you close it
we're in the midst of the greatest is
that country designed to be overstory
for any country I got rid of them
economic boom in history we had the most
people working that we've ever had
almost a hundred and sixty million
people and then from 160 million they
want nobody to leave their house you
know you could use the term cold turkey
right
that's called cold turkey country's not
designed this country is not designed
for that we have to get our country back
and I think it's gonna come back and I
hope it's gonna come back very quickly
he didn't even let her ask a question
that's what's incredible I just
generally am NOT in a like I should
would you like me to wear one right now
and dancing you a question that would be
cool yes but no I mean I again I would
wear one if it was if I thought it was
important she she thinks she likes the
idea of wearing it yeah she does a lot
of people do this Melania like
explanation and I understand that
recommendation and I'm okay with it
[Music]
wouldn't be surprised who she was are
you encouraging them emotionally prepare
for that and while the president is
talking and is eager to see the country
reopen how do we balance the mitigating
factors that still need to take place
before we show that doctors by the way
he'd like to see the company open - I
mean the company is the country
okay so part of the answer to your
question I think relates to two other
questions I heard and I think it came
from the back about how can you on the
one hand have said yesterday that this
is really gonna be a bad week at the
same time that we're talking about the
light at the end of the tunnel it seems
to be inherently contradictory but it
really isn't and it has to do with what
we explained before about the lag and
when you look at the indications that
dr. Burks and the president was talking
about will you see a flattening out of
cases and you don't see the realization
of what that means until two weeks later
so right now we're seeing as we all said
correctly that this is probably gonna be
a really bad week that is a reflection
of what happened two and a half weeks
ago it's laggy so if we start seeing now
a flattening or a stabilization of cases
what you're hearing about potential
light at the end of the tunnel doesn't
take away from the fact that tomorrow
the next day it's gonna look really bad
so we've got to make sure we realize
we're always talking about a two and a
half week lag so I want to make sure
because I think a couple of people asked
that question it's really not
incompatible with what we're saying now
with regard to what do we tell the
American people what Kelly what we've
been telling them all along that the
only tool but the best tool we have is
mitigation we know it worked in other
countries and we're seeing how it's
working here so if we really want to
make sure that we don't have these
of rebounds that were worried about its
mitigation mitigation mitigation that's
the answer it's the same thing it's
mitigation mitigation mitigation in fact
the famous vice-president chock is that
this is the minimum the child we should
be doing you know everyone should be I'm
not seeing enough granularity in this
answer one way or the other points to
physical separation
whether it's no crowds whether it's six
feet whether it's staying away from
theaters and restaurants or what have
you
exactly exactly are you worried all that
after you know seven days from now
people are gonna say look I gave my best
shot I gotta get out you know I wouldn't
say I'm worried about it cuz I don't
think it's gonna happen I mean from what
I've seen and I mentioned that the other
day my own experience is that people
really understand the responsibility
that they have for themselves for their
family and for the country so this is
about all of us this isn't just about us
it is a reasonable question though some
states have been doing this so much
longer that people aren't gonna tolerate
it indefinitely bounds that were worried
about you know we don't know and even
among us good friends that we are we
differ about that I mean it's somewhere
between 25 and 50 percent yeah in other
words about people the FF the people
that are out there no way and trust me
that is a estimate drastic I don't under
any scientific data yet to say that you
know one will get the scientific data
when we get those antibody tests out
there and we really know what the
penetrance is then we can answer the
questions in a scientifically sound way
right now we're just guessing
so weigh in on this issue of
hydroxychloroquine what would you think
about this and what is it what is the
walk about evaluation 15
Trump literally will not let a master
answer what do you mean why am I not
wearing a facemask now okay there are a
couple of reasons one of them is that
part of the effect the major reason to
wear a face mask is to protect you from
infecting you
I had my test yesterday and it's
negative okay these guys are not
coherent on that issue that was a love
that answer especially on the face mask
I thought it was very good record show
Wow federal agencies sure who you in
agencies to begin the ball for you're
summarizing Raiders and are you ready
are you ready
we just answer your question cuz I know
exactly you know same question here
school attack ready they have done an
unbelievable job in delivering for the
Associated Press which is you know not
so great not like it used to be the
people that you're looking at FEMA the
military what they've done is a miracle
what they've done is a miracle in
getting all of this stuff what they've
done for states is incredible
and you should be thanking them for what
they've done not always asking wiseguy
questions thank you very much everybody
thank you wow what a press briefing
Donald Trump literally not allowing not
allowing doctor foul Chi to give his
opinion of hydrochloric win
hydroxychloroquine or chloroquine just
didn't allow him to answer it and
anthony foul he knew he just stood there
he could have answered but he knew he
was not being allowed to do it
unbelievable unbelievable and in fact
let's just I'll just tweet about that in
case people weren't watching
Trump just literally didn't allow dr.
fowey to give his opinion of chloroquine
as a coronavirus treatment stunning
stuff that was a weird moment that was
an extraordinarily odd moment and Wow
Wow
not exactly the type of leadership I
prefer to see okay let me say some thank
yous to folks who have grabbed
memberships on my website while that was
going on Alan Wilson is new member
number 13 today Christy Lewis is new
member number 14 Emily gentlemen I hope
I'm pronouncing that correctly is number
15
Matthew Cinco is number 16 today
Esther polder is new member number 17 at
join pakman.com also want to say a huge
thank you to Rebekah Grabowski Rebekah
Grabowski Stuart Burstein whose new
member number 19
Tracy do 4 is new member number 20
Tiffany Robles is new member number 21
thanks Tiffany Shannon McLennan I hope
that I got that one right Maurice Morgan
is new member number 23
Douglas lusin hop is new member number
24 seems to be escalating difficulty
sandra shirk is new member number 25 and
paula white is new member number 26 now
I may actually have missed
Oh Annie Lee Bert I don't want to forget
who's number 27 today if Sean Khurana is
new member number 28 David rich that one
I feel very good about is number 29 and
that I believe catches me up yes indeed
the number one way to support the
streams is to simply grab a membership
at join pakman.com ok a couple of quick
things before we wrap here okay this is
so I'm going to talk more about this
tomorrow Jared Kushner made a completely
sinister and ominous appearance at a
recent press conference
here's 58 seconds of Jared Kushner
walking and literally saying nothing I
challenge you okay tell me what
substance Jared Kushner presents in
these 58 seconds what the president
asked is that all of the recommendations
that we made be based on data he wanted
us to be very rigorous to make sure that
we were studying the data collecting
data a lot of things in this country
were happening very quickly
and we want to make sure that we were
trying to keep updating our models and
making sure that we were making informed
decisions and informed recommendations
to him based on the data that we were
able to collect and put together the
president wanted to make sure that we
had the best people doing the best jobs
and making sure that we had the right
people focused on all the things that
needed to happen to make sure that we
can deliver in these unusual times for
the American people
the president also instructed me to make
sure that I break down every barrier
needed to make sure that the teams can
succeed this is a an effort where the
government is doing things that the
government doesn't normally do where
we're stretching where we're acting very
quickly and the president wants to make
sure that the White House is fully
behind the different people running the
different lines of effort to make sure
that we get everything done in a speed
that the president demands he literally
said nothing I don't know that I've ever
seen someone say so many words and say
what what is it that's been done that he
just told us data's being used to make
decisions at a speed that the president
wants we want people working in the
areas in which they can be most of what
have you done
what can you state one actual thing that
has taken place here I've never seen
anything like that and I am NOT saying
that anybody can even suggest anything
actually that was communicated during
that okay as I said I have a hard out at
the bottom of the hour since the press
conference is over we will end our
coverage today I'll be back tomorrow
clips podcast tweets and of course
probably another one of these press
conferences tomorrow